(♪ DJ Raff - Latino N' Proud)
- Put it on my tab, Arnie.
- You got it.
- (laughing) Got it!
For 10, we were gonna
do as the first episode
one that was maybe
three or four rewrites
to figure out.
And then once we figured
out that sort of noir tone,
then it started coming together.
(dramatic music)
- [Ilana] No!
(gasp)
- [Abbi and Ilana] Holy shit!
- You know, it's
almost the first time
that we see Abbi and Ilana
have any real tension.
Because we love just
having two characters
that are unconditional
friends that are women,
but this was the first
time that we allowed
them to have that tension.
- Well, it was the forgetting
something really important
about the relationship.
- Great, thank you so much.
- Yeah, okay, are you mad?
- (sighs) Not mad,
just informed.
- Like, for Ilana
in the episode,
it's hard for her not
to take it personal,
but it's all there.
You don't really
need this anniversary
to say what good friends we are.
- You're my
everything, and I wanna
tell you something
before we die.
- Okay.
- This morning, I was the horse.
- What?
- Were you gonna
tell me about Leanne?
- (Ilana laughs)
- Okay, there is this
Easter Egg of a joke,
that is like, one of
my favorite jokes.
In 10, when we walk, and this
is like the dumbest thing.
In 10, when we walk
into this karaoke bar
to follow this guy, there's
a man singing a song
that's called Leanne.
- [Man] Leanne! We are Leanne!
- It is a song that we made up
and our music supervisor
Matt FX produced.
- [Abbi And Ilana] Leanne
- I am Leanne.
We're all Leanne.
Something like that.
- (Abbi and Ilana laugh)
- And it plays throughout
the entire season.
On the radio, in cabs.
It plays throughout
the entire season.
- In "The Mushrooms," when
Abbi's changing the music,
I'm nervous.
- (♪ Leanne)
- (Abbi sighs)
- It goes
- [Abbi and Ilana]
Leanne, Leanne
- Well it just like,
what's the pop song,
and it's playing everywhere.
- I am
- [Abbi and Ilana]
Leanne! We are Leanne!
- (♪ Leanne)